where does philosophy
begin and end does it have
borders or boundaries in asking this
we're really asking not just about
philosophy itself
but about its relationship to an
other to generally some other
discipline some other activity some
other literature some other
commitment and way of living and there
have been a lot of
candidates throughout the years we're
going to talk briefly about
rhetoric early on in philosophy religion
science and history including
philosophies own
history and you know if you if you
read through much philosophy sooner or
later
you're going to run into people who want
to make distinctions
along these lines and say there's some
sort of
division some sort of distinction some
sort of border
some sort of boundary and on this side
lies philosophy
on this side lies the something else
and there's a lot of different ways of
construing this i will point out that
just as
there is no consensus definition of what
philosophy
is or could be or should be there is no
absolutely agreed upon distinction
so when you read people saying
philosophy
is here and theology is here and this is
the
just the way it is you've got to take
that with a little grain of salt and if
you look at history that will help you
to to some degree contextualize if not
necessarily
relativize and entirely throw out these
attempts
at providing dividing lines that are
hard and fast
and when we see attempts like this
one of the key questions we want to ask
right away is
all right you've got a division that
you're making here what's your criterion
for that
is there a single way of saying
what lies on this side what lies on this
side is it a complex
of different ideas different
distinctions that are overlapping
with each other well that's that's a
significant
question another question that we have
to ask is
who's providing these criteria did they
just
pop into our heads were they worked out
over time are they the result of
somebody
imposing by fiat or are they something
that every
every rational person ought to be able
to see
that never actually does happen by the
way is
is the distinction and the criteria
coming from the side of philosophy
is philosophy getting to self-define
itself in relation to its other
or is it coming from the other side and
philosophy takes those
cues from the other discipline or
activity or literature and says okay
i'll accept what you have to say or is
it kind of a mixture of both
and then we can ask another key question
is the relationship between philosophy
and this other
discipline supposed to be neutral
is it cooperative is it
antagonistic is it a case of
subordination and super ordination where
maybe philosophy
stands above that discipline and tells
it what to do
or where philosophy takes its cues
or should take its cues from that other
discipline or set of disciplines or
activity well these are
all important questions and these are
all
part of the picture whenever anybody
invokes something like
you know you got philosophy and then you
got theology and it's really easy to
tell the difference between the two of
them
you know when thomas aquinas brings up
the bible he's doing theology when he's
bringing up bearish level he's doing
philosophy
you can say well what's your warrant
what's your evidence what's your
assurance what's your argument
for using that criterion who told you
that was right
right that's a good valid question to
ask
and that is a philosophical question
so philosophy you know once it starts to
think about itself is always involved in
meta philosophical questions about its
relation
to other things let's talk about a few
of these
right so early on
you know if we think about plato and
there's also you know similar
relationship and discussion going on in
aristotle in cicero in others philosophy
gets counter posed to rhetoric
and often rhetoric gets lumped under
sophistry right
and the sophists were these people who
wandered around
claiming to teach a variety of different
things many of them were
older or contemporaries of socrates some
of them
only claim to teach rhetoric like
gorgeous some of them claim to teach all
sorts of other things
as well and philosophy is supposed to be
something
better than that philosophy is supposed
to
get us to real wisdom whereas the
sophists just have a pretense of wisdom
there's a line being drawn right and who
gets to draw that line
well it's the philosophers and we should
be a little bit
you know leery sometimes about being too
uncritically
accepting about what plato has to say
given that his own student
aristotle thought that it was important
to write a book called the
art of rhetoric and in that book argues
that
in book three of the art of rhetoric
that
rhetoric is very important because all
teaching involves some persuasion you
know attending to the audience
rhetoric could be done in a way that was
more informed by philosophy had a less
antagonistic relationship with
it interestingly at the same time that
aristotle
is teaching isocrates one of the great
rhetoricians
has his own school where he's teaching
rhetoric
in the same place as the same city
as aristotle and his these these people
are referencing
back and forth and so there's this long
tangled history cicero gets involved in
it
later on in the
renaissance and onward we see
other thinkers bringing up the
importance of rhetoric for
philosophy we can still make a
distinction between them
but perhaps the distinction is less of a
strict
border and more like
you know several people living in the
same house
and working with each other and
consulting each other from time to time
another really big one religion
in western philosophy what we're mostly
thinking about are the
abrahamic monotheistic faiths of judaism
christianity and islam
but we could apply this to other
conceptions of religion and it's not as
if the greeks and romans didn't have
their own
rights rituals entire mythologies and
understandings of religion which varied
from time to time there were
philosophical
understandings of religion that we find
in plato
in the stoics in a variety of other
thinkers going all the way into late
neoplatonism
and quite often this is different than
the religion that the ordinary person on
the street might be practicing
so already religion is kind of a messy
term just like philosophy
no strict agreed upon definition of it
but we can say that you know
at some points religion
and philosophy drew upon each other and
at other points could be
quite hostile to each other what we're
interested in is
the people that are saying well you've
got religion on one side
or faith or theology or pick whatever
other term you want
and then you've got philosophy on the
other side and it might be in terms of
the criterion of
this is a purely rational natural
activity
this is a somewhat irrational informed
by revelation activity
and that distinction you know you can
say well
again who gets to make that is that a
distinction on the side of religion is
that a distinction on the side of
philosophy
when we make these distinctions and we
try to see what fits into what side
what do we what do we make of previous
thinkers their literature their activity
how philosophy is understood as a
discipline does that mean that we have
to push
plato onto the side of religion because
he
references religious con concepts and
brings up myths
socrates himself refers to his dimon
you see how complex and complicated
this can get another one science
and here we're talking about in the
modern era
and really the late modern era because
philosophy
was understood as a science an apistame
right or a techne or you know a sophia
kind of wisdom
throughout the ages a skientia in in
latin
and the other sciences you know some of
them were you know
developing alongside philosophy like
mathematics or medicine
others came out of philosophy physics
was part of philosophy
psychology part of philosophy originally
sociology part of philosophy
originally even economics starting out
as household management
and then eventually becoming political
economy there are all these back and
forth things but
you know nowadays we think of the
sciences as as being their own sort of
thing and having their own scientific
method which
they very often don't operate according
to the textbook scientific method it's
way more complicated than that but this
is this became a going concern
how can we separate philosophy off
from these sciences like the natural
sciences
like the social sciences all these other
things that might figure into it some
things that maybe
maybe they are a science maybe they
aren't like linguistics
right some things involving technology
is there a nice dividing line
that we can draw some people thought of
philosophy
as essentially coordinating all of the
other sciences for example
positivists like herbert spencer
and august compt in the 19th century
others thought that the sciences really
ought to
you know be handling the real problems
and then philosophy handles the
leftovers like
aj air and other logical positivists
of that time and then some people think
that there should be
fruitful interaction between it there's
even something we call philosophy
of science where you know we think about
what is an experiment
how do we tell whether an experiment was
successful
or not is that part of science or is
that part of philosophy
and there's you know the verdict is kind
of out
when it comes to this strict dividing
line
another one that comes up within
philosophy has to do with history
some people practicing or teaching
philosophy will say
well you've got real philosophy over
here and then you've got the history of
philosophy over here
history of philosophy is basically about
what other people thought
back in the day and we try to get clear
about that but real philosophies over
here where we're doing something new
something innovative something that's
leaving behind that history
and then you know a lot of people within
the history of philosophy say
wow you really got it wrong that's why
your philosophy keeps reinventing wheels
that you know
descartes already handled or the stoics
already discussed or
plutarch who you never read discussed
right you're
spending a lot of time doing things that
you think are new that
aren't actually new maybe it'd be better
to be informed by the history
of philosophy maybe that's what real
philosophizing would consistent once
again we see
a dividing line being set that that
people don't really
agree upon so you know you notice that i
i'm saying here as well that narratives
and history
figure into this i think personally
that having studied you know quite a bit
within the history of philosophy and the
history of ideas
is very helpful for realizing that
although we can draw
lines between philosophy and other
disciplines or activities
these lines are typically rather
arbitrary
we may have criteria but we have to ask
where those criteria came from
and studying the history of the ideas
helps to answer that
we also need to look at the narratives
that help
us understand why people took these
positions so
for example you know why did people say
oh you know religion is over here
philosophy is over here perhaps one of
the narratives is
religion is irrational something that
we're going to leave behind
and philosophy will take its place this
is associated
with a period that we call the
enlightenment in
the west in which many many people were
working out ideas like that
and they were casting the medieval
period as the dark ages in which
faith ruled and philosophy could not
have its full sway
well those narratives may be accurate or
they may be
self-serving things that function as an
ideology for people so we need to
be rather careful about that this is not
to say that we can't make any
distinctions whatsoever between
philosophy and other activities
disciplines literatures uh but it is to
say that we should exercise a little bit
of
common sense a little bit of caution a
little bit of
judgment and we should be a bit
suspicious
about these very neat dividing lines
that people would like to make
oftentimes
within the philosophical literature
discipline activity itself
you